Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and so much just
happened in the Arrow Finale.
They resolved most of the important stuff,
definitely left us hanging on a few big things
and we got a pretty good idea for what’s
going on in Season 3.
So here’s what I’m going to do.
I’ll start with Top 5 moments, then do my
review and then talk about Season 3 theories.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I do Arrow videos every week.
Now that The Flash is coming I’ll be doing
bonus videos for that too.
Probably still on Wednesdays.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything and
leave me suggestions for bonus vids.
So careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
the episode yet, but here are my top 5 moments.
Number 5 - Roy Gets His Suit
That speech Oliver gave him was the same speech
Barry Gave to Oliver back in episode 9 during
the Flash crossover.
That’s when Barry gave Oliver his Green
mask.
So Roy’s mirakuru crash and burn is going
to inform his character in season 3.
And since Thea is gone he’s sticking around.
You don’t get a hero shot like he did in
the tunnel and then just dump the character.
Although there have been some live action
Young Justice rumors.
I think the costume is great.
It’s basically a version of Stephen Amell’s
costume.
He’ll probably be hoodie bound for most
of season 3.
But it’s really the mask that makes it a
costume.
I think his bow and arrows are the same type
Oliver uses.
They’re just going to have to order double
the supply from now on.
Number 4 - Thea goes with Merlyn
I think we expected this a little.
But I had no idea what was going to push her
over that ledge.
And it turned out to be the revelation that
Roy was also lying about his relationship
with the Arrow.
There’s a whole lot we can unpack in the
comments, but the big takeaways are that she’s
toughening up.
Like she’s on the same character arc Sara
was on when she joined the League of Assassins.
She’s the daughter Merlyn always wanted.
He’ll probably help her become the Artemis
persona.
From a comics standpoint it makes the most
sense.
I’ll talk about this more in my Season 3
theories, but she still doesn’t know who
the Arrow is and now that she’s going to
turn into a stone cold killer.
She and Merlyn could become the Season 3 antagonists.
Is Merlyn going to tell her that Oliver is
the Arrow though?
I think they’ll leave that moment for Season
3.
So they’ll both be back.
Number 3 - Amanda Waller Versus The Suicide
Squad
Because we got so much Amanda Waller this
season and given Lyla’s new baby and that
post-credits flashback scene.
I think it’s safe to say we’re going to
see a lot of them next season.
The squad is probably going to evolve with
a new member or two and we’ll learn more
about Oliver’s history with them.
Diggle and Oliver are both Fathers now and
that’s weird.
I thought season 3 would play into the sins
of the father theme even more just based on
Merlyn and Thea and Oliver and his son.
But adding Diggle to the baby list makes it
almost certain.
Which also pretty much guarantees we’ll
see Felicity’s father.
Waller and Oliver’s history is going to
be a lot of fun to dissect.
It sounds like she either contracted him for
special missions or something to do with the
list.
So Waller is going to be the island of season
3.
Even though we still have a link to the island.
Number 2 - Slade To The Wrong Woman
This was a total fake out but I loved the
way they played it, start to finish.
I think twitter exploded when they had the
“I Love You Moment”.
It was all just clever editing and Felicity
was in on the fake out the whole time.
But boy did they take a long time to pay off
that secret camera plot from the promise episode.
And when they were on the beach Stephen Amell
reacted to Felicity in just the right way
as to let you think that he might not have
been acting when he said I love you.
In my opinion he does love her, but not totally
in a romantic way.
and my Number 1 moment - Slade Helps Oliver
Become A Hero
This all goes back to the heroes don’t kill
people thing.
It’s just Oliver getting close to that Justice
League level of hero.
Slade taught him that he can defeat evil without
killing.
That there’s a better way.
That’s why when they were jumping back and
forth between the flashbacks and their fight
at the end.
Oliver ended the flashback by throwing the
serum away and trying to kill him.
Consider that the low point.
They never really addressed the Shado hallucinations
other than Slade said he hated Oliver before
those started.
The big teaser now is that he’s tucked away
in Argus’ new supermax prison on the Island.
In case you didn’t catch the reference,
when Oliver said, there will be more.
He meant they would fight more Deathstroke
level villains and stick them in the underground
prison too.
People way worse than the Suicide Squad members.
I think that eventually each future season
will escalate the number of supervillains
until the series finale in season 7 or 8 or
whenever they end the show.
Will be like Arkham Prison when all the supervillains
were let out at the same time.
Like Oliver’s going to slowly fill that
Argus prison till it’s full.
Then some supervillain will come along and
free everyone and it will be Hell on Earth.
Prison Break Injustice Society Edition.
But now it’s your turn, let me know what
your favorite moments were and whether or
not you think Thea is going to be a villain
next season?
I’ll say the funniest moment was probably
Felicity Versus Nyssa in the battle of introductions.
Felicity Smoak.
MIT, Class of ‘09.
Overall the episode was a solid A. It did
a great job of capping off a season that kept
escalating the stakes to infinity each week
and at the same time setting up Season 3 in
a really exciting way.
Don’t you feel like if you combined a few
scenes from the last 15 minutes or so it would
be a perfect Season 3 trailer.
You have Thea and Merlyn’s new arc, Roy
as a fully realized Arsenal and Team Arrow
moving to a new location with babies.
And Amanda Waller off to the side just staring
daggers at everyone.
The only things I wish they had spent more
time on were Slade and Oliver’s final moments,
not the prison scene, but Slade’s breakdown
and their dramatic moments.
The fight was great.
Both the flashback fight and the current day
one.
We got a peek into Slade’s mind during episode
18 when we learned about evil tinkerbell Shado.
But they might be saving a lot of the cerebral
Slade moments for Season 3 and beyond.
I think it would be fun if it turned into
like a Blacklist thing, where Slade becomes
like James Spader and his daughter is an Argus
person.
On to Laurel and Thea, those two characters
went through the biggest transformations this
season.
Thea’s really just happened in the last
couple of episodes.
As for that jacket, it was definitely the
most on-the-nose reference to the comics.
Especially Quentin’s response.
I think it means that Laurel isn’t going
to be Black Canary for at least one more year.
Think about how long it took Roy to become
Red Arrow.
All Season.
But Thea and Merlyn are really the thing I’m
most excited about.
I’m more excited about them than Oliver’s
baby.
So let’s talk Season 3.
I’m just going to blast through these really
quick and we can follow up in the comments.
Starting with New Arrowcave, the foundry was
trashed, Thea doesn’t own it anymore and
she’s left town.
So they’re not going back there.
Cut to that other site Oliver went to during
Moira’s funeral.
Getting the company back.
I'm not expecting Oliver to be Mayor, but
I think there will be a new cast member that
will help them get the company back.
Or they'll do like in the comics where Oliver
creates a new company and then just buys back
Queen Industries.
New arrow cave new company.
Seems like it fits.
Thea as Artemis.
She’ll probably have a season long arc where
she becomes a version of the Dark Archer.
Like Father like Daughter.
It’s possible that they could become the
season 3 villains, or at least antagonists
for Team Arrow.
Flash Crossover.
We saw the trailer during the episode.
Stephen Amell was helping Barry train.
Plan on him and Felicity being in Flash episode
1 and there to be at least one or two direct
crossovers.
They will have a shared universe.
Argus, The Suicide Squad and Amanda Waller
will all continue to interact with Team Arrow
a couple times a season.
Also, now that we have Lyla and Diggle’s
baby, it’s one more reason to throw to them
in a story.
She’s Argus, so any episode Lyla’s in,
automatically becomes a back door suicide
squad Amanda Waller episode.
Which leads me to Flashbacks.
Now that we know Oliver spent time with Amanda
Waller after he left the island, but before
he returned to Starling.
All the flashback moments will pull from that
time period.
I’m thinking Oliver Argus Agent in China
type stuff.
More opportunities for him to bump into new
villains in the past.
Baby Time.
The mother of Oliver’s child moved to Central
City.
We’ll probably learn more about them and
it will probably be part of a Flash Crossover.
Also Diggle’s baby will probably get tied
up in some new plot too.
He’s not leaving the team.
And Lyla isn’t quitting ARGUS.
The League of Assassin’s and the Canary.
Will cameo at least once.
I’m hoping Team Arrow goes on a road trip
to Nanda Parbat.
That would be sweet.
That’s pretty much it, but if you think
I forgot anything, just write it in the comments
below.
In case you didn’t see it, I posted a breakdown
of the Flash trailer.
and I’m posting my Q&A video tomorrow.
So ask me all your questions for either Arrow
or the Flash.
Right now click here for that Flash Trailer
and Click here for the Q&A.
I’ll add the annotation as soon as I post
it.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!